[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo lo
saludan juliet riaño
[Música]
republicanos y demócratas en eeuu viven
desde hace una semana un nuevo tira y
afloja esta vez con los migrantes de por
medio gobernadores republicanos del sur
del país de estados como texas y arizona
los están enviando en buses gratis hacia
washington en una nueva jugada para
presionar al presidente joe biden y
pedirle que se responsabiliza de los
recién llegados los buses también tienen
como destino nueva york un estado
liderado por un demócrata más romeros
nos cuenta más
llegará una nueva york después de 36
horas viajando en un autobús pagado por
el estado de texas son migrantes
irregulares y pisan por primera vez la
ciudad con esperanzas pulsamos
venezuela colombia panamá costa rica
[Aplausos]
[Música]
guatemala méxico y texas tenemos muchas
muchas deseo de trabajar de trabajar
salir adelante iniciar una nueva vida
una nueva vida que el gobernador tejano
el republicano greg abbott no quiere que
vivan dentro de su estado
desde abril el político ha pagado buses
para transportar más de 6.200 migrantes
de washington la capital de eeuu y en el
vecino estado de arizona su homólogo
doctus y siguió su ejemplo con mil
personas más
es parte de una estrategia para
presionar al presidente joe biden y a
los alcaldes demócratas a quienes acusan
de flexibilizar sus políticas
migratorias sin responsabilizarse de
atender a los migrantes va a ir en
rechazo a hacer su trabajo así que texas
sigue dando pasos sin precedentes para
asegurar nuestra frontera nueva york- es
el destino ideal para estos migrantes
pueden recibir los servicios de los que
el alcalde adams ha presumido tanto en
su ciudad santuario sin embargo la
bienvenida en estas ciudades no ha sido
tan cálida los servicios sociales están
desbordados y muchos de estos migrantes
terminan durmiendo en la calle o en
albergues
y mientras los migrantes solicitan asilo
y buscan trabajo un proceso que dura
meses y pone a prueba cualquier
esperanza los republicanos y demócratas
las alcaldías las gobernaciones y el
gobierno federal se responsabilizan unos
a otros de este repunte de llegadas
desde octubre eeuu ha detenido a más de
un millón 700 personas en la frontera
con mexico el récord desde 1960
y es precisamente en la frontera sur
donde se concentra la atención por temas
migratorios ese es el cruce obligado
para la mayoría de personas que buscan
llegar y quedarse en eeuu pero muchos
desconocen los peligros reales de esta
travesía el muro es uno de los
principales bloqueos para evitar el
tránsito y también es uno de los pasos
más riesgosos recientemente la casa
blanca informó que está reparando
algunas brechas para reducir el riesgo
esto pasa en los estados que limitan con
méxico
con un muro en parte de su frontera sur
de más de 3000 kilómetros de longitud
eeuu busca persuadir a los migrantes de
su viaje al norte pero pese a las
advertencias el éxodo no para y las
muertes en el tránsito aumentan aunque
los registros son irregulares ya que no
todos los cuerpos son encontrados
no se les dice lo malo que puede ser
realmente creen que es tan sencillo como
venir estás aquí eres libre es fácil
irse y no funciona así sabes y ahí es
donde todo termina en lesiones y con
desafortunadas víctimas en toda la
frontera suroeste el año pasado fue el
más mortífero para los migrantes que
cruzaron la frontera entre eeuu y méxico
728 perdieron la vida en 2021 según la
onu en este hospital de san diego los
ingresos por lesiones relacionadas con
el paso por el muro fronterizo
aumentaron considerablemente más desde
que el expresidente donald trump decidió
construir una valla más altas
209 accidentes entre 2019 y 2021
ese muro fronterizo se extiende desde el
océano hasta el este a lo largo de
varias decenas de kilómetros hay
pequeñas brechas aquí y allá pero las
zonas en las que se están lesionando son
principalmente en el área metropolitana
de san diego y están cayendo
directamente al condado de san diego
después de saltar sobre la propia valla
fronteriza las llamadas de auxilio
también aumentaron los rescates a lo
largo de la frontera suroeste superaron
ya los 14 mil desde el inicio del año
fiscal 2022
entonces las llamadas que recibimos este
año para el año fiscal aumentaron más
del 25 por ciento en comparación con el
año pasado en la misma época recibimos
aproximadamente 16 llamadas por día
todos los días llamadas al 911 pese a
vivir los peligros en carne propia
muchos cruzan la frontera una y otra vez
y de formas más arriesgadas para evitar
ser detectados por las autoridades
el flujo migratorio durante 2022 hacia
eeuu se encamina a ser uno de los más
altos los datos reportados hasta ahora
por la organización internacional para
las migraciones indican que más de un
millón de encuentros se reportaron de
enero a mayo siendo los hondureños y
guatemaltecos los que más buscaron
cruzar y el dato de migración de la
semana más de 18 mil migrantes cruzaron
este año el canal de la mancha que
separa las islas británicas de europa
continental para responder a las
llegadas por esta vía reinó unido- puso
en marcha un polémico plan para enviar a
los solicitantes de asilo a ruanda
mientras se esperan una respuesta a sus
peticiones
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]